OK, a little bit of election news.
I have really good news for people.
Disgusting extremist idealogue right winger
Congressman Steve King from Iowa, lost.
I'm sorry, from Indiana.
Lost his Republican primary last and sorry,
Iowa lost his primary yesterday and is being
kicked out of Congress in January.
This is truly a disgusting guy, and I am so
glad.
In the midst of just terrible things going
on in our country to be able to tell you about
something good that has taken place.
They voted yesterday.
Steve King has been ousted by state Senator
Randy Feen.
Stre King has a history of racially toxic
comments.
He once waxed nostalgic about how the term
white supremacist doesn't didn't used to be
offensive.
He is irrationally anti-immigrant.
He once compared immigrants to dogs and dirt.
In 2013, he said that young documented immigrants
have.
This is a quote, calves the size of cantaloupes
because they haul 75 pounds of marijuana across
the desert.
He wanted an electrified fence between the
U.S. Mexico border.
He's complained white people aren't having
enough babies to keep up with the rapid reproduction
of minorities.
He endorsed a white nationalist running for
the mayor of Toronto, and he also met with
Austrian far right political party leaders,
a party that was founded by a neo-Nazi.
So he's a horrible guy.
He was widely abandoned by the Republican
Party.
And that's why, you know, this is not glorious
news.
It's great that King has lost.
But the person he lost to Randy Veenstra is
not great.
And in fact, what's scary is that Feen stre
is running on or ran on, Steve.
King is not an effective ally for Donald Trump.
I can be an effective ally for Donald Trump
and his big issues are to keep the Trump tax
cuts to protect Christian values.
Not exactly the best guy scary, but hopefully
Trump himself will be removed in November.
And Feen Stro won't ever, ever get a chance
to serve with Trump even better, by the way.
Is that JD Scholten?
Our friend J.D. Scholten, who unsuccessfully
ran to unseat Steve King back in 2018, is
running again.
So we don't have to see Randy Veenstra win.
Let's support J.D. Scholten, great guy, former
professional baseball player.
I interviewed him back in 2018.
He is running again.
He is the Democrat running against Randy Veenstra.
Let's support him.
Excellent, excellent candidate.
We'll have continued coverage of yesterday's
election results on The David Pakman Show
Instagram page.
That's David Pakman show all one word on Instagram.